we've already kicked it i guess guys
welcome to episode 102
i hope that's the episode number because
it ain't 100.
we already did oh this is 101. okay we
already did 100.
100 is a thing of the past welcome to
101. this is the new
that's right 101 101 and jake's birthday
that's right um so we have a very we
have a very special guest today but
uh i just must say yesterday everyone
thought it was my birthday
and uh it wasn't and i realized that was
because
a long long time ago there was a
platform called facebook
uh and i deleted my original account and
then uh
i realized that i could not access
corridors facebook account unless i
personally had a facebook account so i
tried to make one well it took
months in the making because every time
i tried to make an account they thought
it was a fake account
for some reason so um i was very fed up
and i think at one point i had given
them the wrong birth date and then
somehow that stuck around and so now
everyone thinks my birthday is uh july
27th
so i'm just gonna yeah because because
jordan saw that i was with her at the
time and she was like oh it's did you
know it's jake's birthday today
i was like oh [ __ ] i texted you yeah
everybody
and then she posted on the on the story
on instagram
i really appreciate it i really
appreciate everyone like
you know saying happy birthday it was
really nice how many dms did you get did
you get a lot of birthday dms
yeah man probably like 10 people
yesterday said happy birthday to me
i haven't i've yet to decide if i should
have this kind of extended like
awkward conversation about how it was in
fact not my birthday or
i should just say thank you it was great
yeah it's like christmas in july
yeah see i was authentically going to
send you a birthday message and forgot
and i felt bad that i had to say happy
belated birthday jake
but turns out
oh man it was deep down i knew that it
wasn't actually your birthday so let's
go yeah he just knew he knew you too
well
but anyway this episode is not about me
we have a very special guest today a man
named
joshua jewelry what's going on buddy
[Laughter]
this is actually my first podcast so
from a little bit all the time
it's my first time it's it's my favorite
podcast so
really it's kind of a pleasure to be
your guest on here for the first time
wow
thanks and that's gonna be weird when
you listen to this like in your car
later yeah
i always go back and listen to him to
make sure i didn't say anything stupid
but usually that never comes out to be
true
it's inevitable yeah yeah at this point
you just give up yeah
um but joshua's got a very awesome
instagram
and uh that's kind of i mean nico you
were the first one to see the work so
yeah i guess uh well me i mean i don't
know if anybody else happened to
come across what i did but uh yeah you
know it just popped up on reddit one day
um you were doing these cool little you
know short single shot vfx
kind of moments uh the thing that stood
out to me is you know a lot of people
when they do like the little vfx magic
tricks
on instagram or tick tock or fine
whatever um
you know usually it's uh like you know
hidden cuts match cuts kind of like
stuff that doesn't really require
generating imagery but you're working
with things you've already captured with
the camera and sometimes it's super
complicated you know you have to film
like five or six different elements to
get them all together get them lined up
get the light in a match come back
different times etc
but josh you're doing you're doing your
work with actual 3d modeling
and dynamics and physics and comping all
that in and
also dealing with a lot of like you know
having yourself in the shot and then
like you get chopped in half
and so you're working with that seamless
transition from real footage to
3d footage so it caught my eye and it
was fun and the other thing that like uh
stood out to me was that you'd have you
tell a little a little itty-bitty story
with each one too
yeah um so i thought they were cool and
we ended up kind of touching base and
uh throughout the spring uh you know as
we started talking about hiring more cgi
generalists we ended up talking to josh
moore and now you're out visiting la and
kind of seeing what
corridor life is like out here yeah it's
it's been quite nuts actually like
meeting you guys in person is
it's mind-blowing seeing you guys and
playing smash against you guys was a big
thing we had going
on the first day i kind of like trash
talked everybody
and like everybody got like a really
really into it i guess so when we played
smash
the first time i actually lost the dean
because uh
i was really good though it was the
first time playing and it's like
everyone was
like it was the first time playing with
like so many people watching
and it's like i'm very nervous about it
and uh like i've never actually gotten
that nervous playing a game in front of
this man
dean beat me the first game but then i
was able to beat him the second game
and then uh during the whole chirping
kind of thing i told
nico that i could beat him with his
player ganon
and uh i got close but i i made a bunch
of two stocks
i made a bunch of mistakes which kind of
uh
resulted in me losing but if we play
again and i'm less nervous i know i
could beat him
okay maybe a couple less people it's
like
i'm getting to play them more and more
now so it's like i'm kind of getting
used to like
feeling a little bit more confident when
i'm playing so it's not okay
i'm not shaking it's not like everyone's
like watching kind of thing so
see you beat dean though yeah i'd be
dean once eventually
[Laughter]
i think if we did another 1v1 now i
think i could do a lot better
um better better on the first uh better
than the first day sorry
that's going to happen you know what's
wrong yeah oh it's going to happen
you're going to be doing some 1v1
watch yeah yeah yeah you guys like
that's the thing they don't show is they
all
play like one game of like eight people
and it's like right it's a really good
idea because then like it blends
everyone's skill levels in because then
it's like teams are free-for-all kind of
thing
but yeah it's uh it's a lot different
than what i'm used to like i play like
tournament stages and like
yeah yeah i play like real like
competitively in the sense where it's
like 1v1s
no like weird mechanics coming out or
like you don't pay
you don't play chaos environments all
the time
what josh is trying to say is that he
could beat us if he was in a controlled
one-on-one tournament style
which by the way we did and i spiked him
if we do it again then i think i could
beat nico i know i can i know i can be
all right all right
challenge accepted challenge accepted
i'll say this right now though i know
exactly how you feel because when i
was in the tournament just as a
throwaway person they were like oh we
need more people to be in this
tournament so here go ahead matt
can we just get this going right now can
we forget about the podcast
i was super nervous though i i didn't
think i would care that much
but like with everyone watching and
stuff
it was like there's so much more
pressure like it feels like a tournament
yeah you know when you're there so it's
like it makes it so fun
yeah yeah yeah well i can't wait to do
this one because next time
mind you i was also super novice at
smash bros and now i'm a little bit
better so
you're decent you're decent decent
enough you guys should have a summer
tournament while i'm here and then have
another one at the end of the year
if we get our work done early we'll have
maybe a little informal bracket okay
that would be fun yeah that would be fun
that would be super fun
all right so so joshua you're
you're in town filming with us this week
i mean
what what did you get what are you guys
working on and uh
i'd also like to hear just kind of i
think everyone would like to hear a
little bit of just about how you got
started
like um and then you know what what
what it's been like this week uh working
on the video we've been
putting together and anything else
really that you wanna
you wanna chat about actually i think we
should start with that question of where
you got started like how you got into
effects i will actually sorry real quick
just a little bit more context for
everybody listening
josh you live up in toronto you are 23
23
um and josh is basically you know he's
doing it himself uh
you know he's just he just started doing
visual effects on his own and he's
making his own thing so it's not like
we're talking to a guy who's hired by
like a vfx studio right now it's just a
guy who's out there
it's like the internet i got a computer
and make it happen
all right yeah well it pretty much
started from like watching you guys like
i thought your videos were like the
coolest videos
and like i tried a few times like making
a full-time like
youtube video or like a full-length
youtube video but it's like for one
person to like plan
film like got all the props and
everything together it takes a lot of
time and then like after you film it you
have to edit it and it's like
for one person like a two minute video
three minute video it can take you a
month
so it's like i was kind of like hoping
for the youtube like route to work but
i'm like
in the back of my mind i'm like i don't
think this is going to work with one
person unfortunately
and then like the years of like youtube
kind of like slowly getting into like
more long term or like longer content
and like less of short content i'm like
i i don't think i could do this at all
so i'm like oh what's another way i
could do it so i'm like oh let's try
doing like instagram posts or like tick
tock and stuff like that so i'm like
let's think of something that can happen
within 10 seconds
make like not like a kind of a story to
it or like something people could relate
to or like a catch phrase or something
like that
like i have one where uh a tongue
twister
like i'll say a tongue twister and then
afterwards my tongue is actually twisted
and it falls out so it's like it's kind
of like you can kind of put the two
together and like it's not just the
random effect of like
me standing there and then next thing i
know i blow up or anything like that i
try to have like a little bit of like
context to what what's about to happen
and stuff like that so uh
the raison d'etre yeah yep yeah i think
the thing i like a lot about your videos
is how you subvert
people's expectations about what's about
to happen like
you really never know exactly what what
you're gonna do
visually um yeah and that yeah
when you when you're approaching these
videos like when you first started was
that kind of always the mindset
it's to kind of like yeah it's uh like i
it's funny because
when i was looking online everyone was
making like satisfying renders and stuff
like that
i'm like nobody's making unsatisfying
runners
like that weird kind of niche that like
i know i'm not like
like i don't really like violence or
anything like that so it's like my
videos are like there is a little bit of
like i get chopped in half with a break
or something like that but
i don't really like violence but i do
get split down the middle of one of my
videos but it's like i'm not trying to
do it in a gory way i'm trying to do
like a cartoony kind of like comic kind
of way like it's the best way i describe
what i do is like looney tunes in real
life
because like their physics are very
messed up and like just things don't
really work out but they're kind of like
cartoony
so it's like i do that for like for the
example where i got cut in half with the
rake i use
like a texture of a meat like a steak
because i'm like what else can i put in
here that won't be too graphic kind of
thing so i'm like let's
put a texture of a steak and go from
there kind of thing
but yeah it's like when i started it was
like
let's try something different and like
unexpected kind of thing so it's like
let's call this series expect the
unexpected kind of thing
and then i just started out making like
these videos of like okay
a tree can fall onto a house and break
the house or like the tree breaks off
but like what else could happen like
what's the weirdest thing that could
happen
like oh what happens if it turns into
like mud or liquid as soon as it hits
the tree it's like
people are like oh wait that tree's
about to fall and then like
oh what yeah kind of thing it gives them
like those emotions
like there's multiple emotions when it
happens and i think that's what like
it kind of makes it work for me like i
have people like really liking my
content and like oh
i get tons of shares like it's a lot of
people are sharing my content and like
sending it to their friends and stuff
like that
and it's like it's the coolest thing
people like sending it to their friends
and then seeing the reactions of their
friends once they're tagged they're like
oh this is gross why would you tag me in
this and stuff like that
it's like it's just funny like seeing
this whole like community of people
like sharing my work and getting
reactions from it i think that's kind of
um
a niche that no one else was seeing um
or not not very many people were seeing
before you started doing it um
which is uh a lot of you think about the
standard user experience right on a
platform
such as instagram you're scrolling
through
you know there's a video it all it
starts auto playing
and immediately there's an expectation
set right
whether it's like a tree falling on a
house and and normally
what you'd see is a tree fall on
somebody's house
and you'd go you'd watch it because holy
crap a tree just fell out of this
person's house you don't see that every
day
but then you immediately like you said
shift the expectation upside down and
that that also makes it really memorable
because you may have seen you know
and of course once you watch one tree
falling on a house video instagram's
gonna serve you eight more
because now now it thinks you're like an
arborist
right um and so but that one you're
gonna remember more
than the other ones because it was you
know it flipped your expectations around
um and i think you're naturally
capitalizing on that
even if you may not have set out to
necessarily
perfect that i think in what you're
doing you have done that
yeah i i didn't really have that in mind
it was more just like
the surprise factor kind of like
have somebody watch the video and be
like what what's going on
like and then they have to re-watch it
to kind of process it again and then
like after the third time they're like
okay we finally understand what's going
on here
yeah and uh my favorite thing too is
like on the way here
uh i came with my dad to california and
like
he's telling all his friends about me
and like i have to explain
like to these like slightly older
gentlemen and women like what i do
yeah so it's like i show them my
instagram and i never know the reaction
i'm gonna get because like it's hard to
like tell people
what i'm doing to like an older
generation so i always like pull up my
phone and like
this is the video i made i hope you like
it
and then it shows me like uh like
spinning around like my tar
like my top part of my body like
spinning around while my legs like stay
one way
they're like oh wow but they're always
laughing and they're always like wow
this is really good and then they always
want to watch more
and it's like these people are like 70
years old 60 years old and i'm like wow
i'm
even like tapping into like the older
generation markets and like like this
content
it's it's honestly so cool like elderly
tick-tockers yeah
it's like geriatric tick-tockers yeah
i know i see you out there
no it's just so cool because like i
never knew
like this content could be like accepted
by so many people i thought it was just
gonna be a very very small niche like
group of people
but the fact that i can like show it to
pretty much anyone and they're like wow
that's
really good like what program do you use
is the main one what app do you use or
something like that
that's my favorite i get them all the
time it's like what app do you use and
[Laughter]
for one joke i uh i like to throw in
jokes and my breakdown and stuff like
that because i'm not
for my breakdown videos i'm not really
trying to tell people
how to do it i'm just showing you kind
of how i did it
so it's like i'm not going to tell you
step by step on each like steph kind of
thing
now at the end of one of my tutorials
i'm like these are all the apps i
uh use because uh everyone was asking
and i like had all the programs pop up
and there was like nine programs i had
used for that video
it's like each one popped up like
houdini after effects marvelous design
cinema 4d and octane and all this stuff
and like just
any of these apps and you should be fine
to make this thing
so but they're just 99 cents on the
store right
so you could just buy it wait how much
is houdini in the app store i don't
how do i do this so i actually have a
question about you know so all this
software
uh you know one of the things that makes
a piece of stand out is the fact that
you're doing
some pretty high level cg work you know
it looks it's lit well it looks you know
the materials feel realistic the
lighting feels realistic the
physics feel realistic so you're using
houdini for
most of your work in terms of like your
3d generation your physics right yeah
and then you're rendering with redshift
sometimes with octane now
comping in after effects like you have
this whole pipeline right
so how did you initially pick up these
programs like how did you like when you
were like okay i want to start learning
visual effects
and you you have a computer i don't know
it has math blaster or something like
that
okay i need to install something what
happened then
like how did you get how did you get the
software yeah i
um the first one was uh just movie maker
like windows movie maker ever i think
everyone's having a program before
i found a tutorial on how to make a
muzzle flash where like
you get the frame you want to have it
you screw
like you take out the one frame as like
a png and then you paint on a muzzle
flash in like
photoshop or something like that or even
paint paint is what we did
and then you save that frame and then
you put it back in the video
and then you shrink that frame to be as
short as possible
so it's like it goes from the video to
that one frame and then it goes back to
the video and
it looks like you have a muzzle flash
kind of in it i remember watching a
tutorial and then like after week i made
my own tutorial of the exact same effect
and for some reason it just like blew up
and got like 10 000 views
a month and i'm like wow this is this is
pretty cool and i had like this whole
thing where i wanted to like make us
like skid around this whole like movie
maker uh muzzle flash thing
but after you do like five of them
you're like i don't really want to do
this anymore it's like this isn't that
fun
so uh i tried uh we were my brother and
i were working on a video
uh in our backyard and we needed a like
a sniper scope
and you couldn't do like overlays in uh
movie maker yet
so it's like i found sony vegas to be a
program where you can have like
layers to add stuff so i found like a
png of a sniper scope put in
uh put it on uh sony vegas and then
animated the position and then rotation
and all that stuff to like move around
like a sniper scope and like follow the
person
and uh i i started with sony vegas too
because like i looked at after effects
and it's like all the like everything on
the sides in the front i'm like no i
i don't want to learn that it's way too
advanced for like me at
any like i don't want to do that so i i
did sony vegas and then uh
after like three months four months
using sony vegas just kind of doing like
the odds
the odd video kind of thing i'm like
let's try it so i found this tutorial on
how to like
make an intro in uh after effects so i
got after effects like the demo
made this intro rendered it out it was
10 gigabytes the file that i rendered
yeah it was like eight seconds of just
no compression like perfect
perfect quality and i think it was like
the 480 by like something else dude it
wasn't even like the full 1080 at the
time it was just
a tiny huge huge file and uh i just yeah
i started phoning around with after
effects
so quick question for you when you're
like okay movie maker is cool
and you find vegas like through google
searching were you like mom for my
birthday i want
sony vegas the editing software like is
that how it went or did you like
did you pirate it like how did you end
like how did you make that jump
tell us sony vegas no i actually i
actually bought sony vegas you could buy
something
it's because it's okay to pirate when
you're really young and trying
don't do it anymore no in software vegas
i uh i actually bought it because you
can go to the store and you can buy like
the box version of it and i think it was
like 130 or something like that
yeah back before i don't even know if
sony vegas is still a thing or if it's
like a subscription thing or
what it is i think it's still go to the
best buy and get it in a box for 130
yeah yeah so i bought sony vegas for the
first thing and then uh
when i switched over to after effects i
uh i tried uh
i tried the trial which i think it was
30 days and it was actually freddy
who mentioned in one of his videos where
he was like you can just restart the
trial every time
it uh becomes the end it's like you can
make like a new email or whatever it was
and then you could just start over the
30-day trial again so i did that for a
bit and then uh
i'm like this probably isn't it so i
just cracked it
i found out like there's a whole like
place on youtube where you can find like
cracks in these like
video stuff so i ended up cracking that
and then uh watching these guys i saw
them using
uh 3ds max so i'm like oh i got to try
3ds max and with 3ds max you can
actually uh
download like a student version of it
which is like for four years you get it
for free you just have to be a student
i mean i kind of faked the being a
student or you can literally just sign
up as long as you type in your name
like add a university email address they
don't even send you the email to like
i was in high school at this time like
joshua's university
you and you're good no i was in
i was in high school so i mean like i
was in school but like not
yeah the right kind of school i guess
but uh yeah i used that for a while
and uh watching these guys i just tried
like rayfire and fume effects
oh cool those might have been cracked
those ones are a little bit expensive so
yeah
well i'm really curious about this
because i think this is a story that
everybody who's into visual effects
when they're young has to go through
which is you're sitting there on the
sidelines and you have
your apps on your phone and you got you
know you're like windows movie maker and
it's like okay i want to start doing
this stuff
like there isn't really that step like
that easy like okay well here's the
program
here's after effects for kids you know
like there isn't anything like that
it's like well i guess i have to figure
out how to get after effects which is
going to cost me a thousand dollars a
year you know or whatever it is you know
five six hundred dollars a year if you
want the full suite of you know adobe so
it's like
how do you make that jump and i back in
my day it was you when you pirated it
you know
yeah yeah yeah definitely and i don't
know like you know we got we got a
little over 10 years between us in terms
of age and i don't know what your
experience was like
it sounds like it hasn't changed much
but you know i think that's almost like
a barrier to entry is like before you
can figure out how to do visual effects
you have to figure out how to
crack this really these really unique
pieces of software that are so
specialized
hi guys this might look a little funny
it certainly feels funny because i'm
upside down
but i gotta tell you about today's
sponsor story blocks
because what they can do for you is
gonna turn your world
upside down storyblocks is the complete
stock solution
for creators and businesses alike
storybox is constantly
adding new content to their site and
updating it to give you the best
experience possible
they've got amazing unlimited libraries
of high quality 4k
clips b-roll motion graphics after
effects templates
and more all constantly being updated
and worked on all the time
through their unlimited all-access plan
anything you get from storyblocks you
can use
in whatever you want however you want
royalty free we use storyblocks all the
time over here at cord or digital
because it's a great tool in our
creative toolkit and if you're
interested in making your videos better
faster more efficient just head on over
to storyblocks.com
cast to get started that's
storyblocks.com
corridorcast i hope this information
turned your world
upside down oh my arms hurt
oh god okay well there's another thing
there's another thing going on here too
and it's not only just the
you know beg borrow and steal the
software however you can get it
but it's also that you didn't have a
desire
to move on from windows movie maker
until you found the limitation of it
right right right you have this you
started with what you had which was
a windows operating system with windows
movie maker
in this in the operating system and then
you're like okay well this
this thing says it can edit movies
together so
and it's here and it's here and i can
open it so let me give it a
let me give it an mp4 file and see what
happens
and then it's like oh you can't do
layers
in in order to put one image on top of
another you
you need you need to do layers so
so what do you do and then you find a
program that can do layers and then you
find then you
then you work your s work your way
through a series of pros
he's just my headphones disconnected
from my phone
okay
[Laughter]
but then you you go to a layered program
like after effects
and then what happens after that you
find the limitation of what you can do
in after
effects you move to a node based program
and yeah you probably
need i need a third dimension right yeah
and after effects is like here click
this button yeah
click this button it'll make it three
dimensions it's fine there's
look we have the axes gizmo you know
yeah it's yz it's like yeah
yeah okay and so you just kind of kept
working your way through software then
like when did you go like
all right i'm just gonna jump into
houdini like that what did that happen
i uh i i quit 3ds max because
the program like you could think about
your life every time the program starts
up it takes so long to like actually
open up
and like just looking at the black
screen you just really reflect on
yourself
and you get to do that a lot because
i've crashed all the time program is
very
very slow but uh i uh
i went to school and for school i wanted
to go like just the visual effects
because it's like i knew i wanted to do
this for a while now
but uh for every school that i was
looking at they're like you have to have
at least three years two years in
filmmaking and i'm like
i kind of already know how to do this
can i like kind of skip it so i went to
the orientation they told me no and i'm
like
okay cool that's that's awesome guys
like i really
really appreciate that but uh i went to
the first year film i'm like okay let me
just try it
so i went to a two-year program and
after the first year
of like filmmaking and stuff like that
i'm like this i don't think this is it
like
i know this stuff this has cost me a lot
of money i think i can do this on my own
and uh i'm like screw it let's try it
kind of thing
and then afterwards i thought if i want
to do it on my own then i'm definitely
gonna have to learn
like the highest program to have like
the most chance of getting in
so i'm like uh houdini is the one that
everyone's been using for like these
marvel films and like these big
blockbuster films so i'm like
let's try learning houdini so it's like
i downloaded it found like a tutorial
and like it's it's very confusing in the
beginning like there's so many like
there's like so many folders within
folders like there's sop dab swaps and
like
all these different like layers to it
and uh
i remember like watching the tutorial
and like i was on
like another like inside one of the
folders and i didn't realize that
there's only
so many nodes inside each folder so i'm
trying to type in what he's
typing in on his but i didn't realize he
was on like the top part of the folder
and it just kind of screwed me up like
the whole time i'm like typing in the
messenger in the comments like hey man
like how do you
how do you do this like i'm already
stuck on this like my first day
but uh he didn't reply i
scratched the tutorial and found another
tutorial and i kind of figured out okay
this is how this works now and then
from there it's like just watching
tutorials like sand castles was my first
thing
uh lego explosion like uh and like the
lego movies where the explosions build
up
that was a big effect that i liked as
well and
uh at first it was more of like just
doing the effects kind of
just in the program of rendering them
out and uh
not really compositing them with like
real life footage or anything like that
and then afterwards i i can't remember
my first idea like
my first idea for my uh unexpected
series was having a log turn into water
so it's like someone's going down to
light the fire and then once they get
the match in the logs
turns into water and it kind of splashes
down and it was like
okay how am i gonna do this how am i
gonna light this how am i gonna
comp this all in and that's kind of
where i figured out my workflow and i
realized
the renderer in houdini
was a little bit slower and it was a
it's mantra as the
renderer in houdini natively but i'm
like let me try redshift
so i downloaded redshift and then used
redshift for it and it
seemed to work like super fast like i've
never seen like a gpu render
that work or that fast so i uh i tried
that
i was able to do my first ever comp with
the log and spilling down
brought it back into after effects did
the compositing and now it's
it is one of my favorites too because
it's like one of my first ones
so like it has a little like special
spot on my little heart though like hey
this is my first scene of like full cg
with houdini after effects and like
rendered it out and then ever since then
i've been just
getting better and better and finding
out tips on stuff like that so now did
that hit right away or what was the
first video that you made that really
was like oh okay
if i keep doing this i'll get even more
views yeah
i should continue to do this there was
uh there was a few videos i did that
were like kind of getting attraction but
like nothing
like i didn't like just have one video
that did super super well
it was like uh my first video that ever
did well was uh i made this video with
windmills
and they're like spinning but like
they're uh what do you want to call them
props or
propellers or whatever they are we're
like kind of warped
and it was like it was funny when i
posted it on reddit i posted on like all
the like the trippy and like
lsd you know like all those like weird
pages and people are like
what is like what's happening here and
like the amount of people thought it was
like the shutter
speed like oh wow problem like when
you're like filming a helicopter and you
have the same like shutter speed as like
the
prop spelling or is spinning yeah it
like looks like it's just still
so it's like this warping thing and
people kept thinking it was that so like
everybody shared it and like oh this is
real and a bunch of people are thinking
no it's clearly cg like you can see
those people were on acid though so it
was like this whole group of people are
like
it was the first time i've ever
experienced like people like no this is
real and it's like no this is definitely
fake and then i'm like
i love this like this is definitely like
fooling people it's like my favorite
thing
so uh yeah i just kept going
i didn't really have a big hit after
that for a while and then i'm thinking
i think i had three videos in a row that
did super super well
i had one where i was blowing a balloon
and then i popped instead of the balloon
and then right after i did the rake
video where i step on the rake and it
splits me in half
and then the third one was uh i was in
the bus stop and i inflated
it was like with those three like back
to back i think those like really pushed
like my content in front of a bunch of
people and like people were like wow
this guy
makes really good videos and then like i
kind of went down for a bit
and then now i'm on the rise up i guess
but
but yeah it's uh it's been a it's been a
really weird trip and it's like
even with my last video my last video
did like super super well
like i i posted and i i didn't feel the
best about it it was like this is a very
rushed one
i'm like i don't really want to do like
soft bodies anymore like i wanted to
take a like a break and maybe try
something else
but i'm like i'll just finish this video
put it out and then
go on from there so i put it out and
it's just me playing baseball and when i
swing
the bat and miss the ball like my top
part of my body just spins around and
then it gets stuck
facing the wrong way and then i'm like
walking back and forth with like my
chest and my head facing
behind me and my legs in front of me
kind of thing and uh
for some reason reels on instagram just
like pushed it like crazy
and it's like it's at 35 million views
like wow
1.7 million likes and my followers like
pretty much like doubled they're almost
like triple to be quite honest
so it's like i'm almost at 100 000 now
instead of just being on like 30
where i was before it so it's it's nuts
like
it's every time you open up the
instagram app it's like you get
notification and it's like hundred
hundred hundred kind of thing i was like
wow
and it like it was for like two weeks
straight too that was the interesting
part about it so i was like
wow is this going to slow down or like
when's this going to slow down but
yeah it was it was it was a pretty cool
ride i'm not going around
i'm not going to lie have you have you
um
gotten to a point with any of your
videos yet where
you go hey i know that one
i did it and it was successful and i
should probably do another one
but i don't want to do it because i
already did it
artistically have you come to that point
to be quite honest i try not to do
it's like since i don't have anything
like i'm pretty much in charge of what i
make like i don't really have anyone
telling me what to make yet
i have like people's comments saying
like oh man i'm sick of this effect or
do something different or something like
that but it's like i'm enjoying it so
it's like
that's i think that's all that matters
to me is like this is my page and it's
kind of like my portfolio now or it's
turned into my portfolio or resume kind
of thing
but it's like i'm just making the stuff
i feel like making because like
i feel like that's what this whole
creative thing should be about it's like
once you get into the point where you're
like
making stuff for the viewers then it's
less
creative and more work kind of feel to
it
which i mean like i understand if you
want like longevity or something like
that you kind of have to
turn towards more what the viewers like
and stuff like that
but like for right now it's like i'm
having the most fun just making like the
weirdest thing that can come to mind and
executing and then posting and it's like
it seems like a lot of people like that
too
so it's it's kind of a blessing really
that i can just make whatever i feel
like and get a
really good reaction from it so that's
cool yeah yeah
super cool yeah it's always interesting
to hear
different people's uh like journeys on
how they get started because they're all
they're all the same but they're all a
little bit different
you know and um so yeah um
because i remember when when uh
i mean when i first came on board with
sam and nico
um like we were constantly trying to
reinvent the wheel like
every week it was you know and
it was good because we learned a ton
right
and and but it was also like an insane
upstream we were like those salmon you
know
we're just like look i know there's a
spawn point up there
i'm gonna die on my way up to it but
come hell or high water i'm gonna get
there and it was just it was constantly
upstream and it wasn't until we started
to
like get more experienced at
just the process that we started to see
like oh well hey maybe
you know if you if you do this or you
turn this way then it's you know the
stream it doesn't you're not fighting
uphill
as much all the time and you can start
to use some of
like your library and your resume if you
say your portfolio to your advantage
yeah yeah and also that
the you're talking about you know like
your baseball bat swinging video where
you spin around
and how that you know has blown up and
has 35 million views and
that moment when you start to see
everything kind of grow and it all takes
a big step forwards
you know and some people have the
overnight success or like they really
blow up
but most people you know as you work out
your workout you work at it it bumps it
bumps and bumps and you get a big bump
and i was like whoa that's cool and then
you kind of keep working on it and bumps
and bumps and bumps then it happens
again
and like as you keep working at those
big bumps continue to stack up
like you find yourself really with like
a growing number of people that
like your work and you know your
audience has grown um
you know hearing hearing you talk about
like that process and going through
those experiences like
you know it takes me back to like we're
doing that with corridor
and like working through those steps
like we still like it doesn't go away
like you're always building you're
always growing because
you know part of you is always becoming
i guess for lack of a better word
irrelevant right like
things are you know you've made your art
it's been consumed and then it kind of
starts to fade
not everything fades you know but like
something starts to move to the
background
likes you know people's tastes change
what they like changes society changes
like the messages that people want you
know that they attach to themselves too
and your
your art changes and so you're always
changing too and of course you're
growing you know people don't
sit still and so you know even if
like something popped long ago managing
to still find that magic
again and to find a way to connect with
people again it's always
it's always very thrilling when it
happens and doesn't really ever go away
in terms of like that thrill
but you know you brought up a you
mentioned another thing which i wanted
to
ask you about so you know you mentioned
doing something for yourself versus like
what the audience asks for
and you know there's certainly like a
spot in the middle there where it's like
you're not going to be super successful
if you only make things for yourself and
no one else likes it
but also you don't really want to listen
to the person who doesn't like the stuff
that's just kind of crapping on it like
come on won't you do this like you don't
take your cues from that person it's
like okay well i'm gonna
find i'll have to change it you know
it's like they're not they don't have
your best interest in mine
um but you know it's like yeah
yeah but so josh like you know when
you're making your stuff like how much
do you think about
you know the audience and other people
watching that like how much does that
factor in
to your inspiration uh
like i i just do it like because i enjoy
doing it like this stuff is like a lot
of fun to me like it's
yeah i love problem solving so like when
you think of a concept you have to think
of like okay how are you gonna film it
what's the best way of filming it it's
like how am i gonna okay if i
film this this way how is it gonna work
when i edit it and then like once i get
it
in after effects how am i gonna bring it
into 3d and stuff like that
so it's like it's a big like puzzle that
you have to do
each time and it's like it's similar
enough each time but sometimes it's
different and that's like the best part
about this whole thing
so it's like i i love just getting that
feeling of doing it
and it's like every time i post the
video it's like i'm super excited to see
how people take it
but i usually don't try to take it too
much to heart of like okay this video
doesn't do well
it's like my my favorite videos are the
ones that don't perform
like i like my recent video the one
before
where i'm on the swing and i flip over
and like hit the top bar of it
it was like one of my favorites because
it's like it took me so
so much time to figure out how to do
each step of it and i was like okay
how am i gonna get the chain to work the
seats at work my body and then clothes
and then hair all them
like all to work together kind of thing
so it was like it was a big
like process and like took me a lot of
like
thinking and like googling and stuff
like that which was kind of stressful
but like
you also enjoy it a little bit it's a
weird spot where like
you enjoy it and then like once you get
it you're like wow this feels
really good and then once you post it
it's like it's
free for everyone to see kind of thing
and like you can hope people react to it
the same way you feel about it but like
you can never really like gauge if
that's going to be the situation or not
but for me it's like uh these people
that tell me like oh
do this do this do this kind of thing
it's like
i i'd rather not right now because i am
enjoying this like
stuff a lot the way i'm doing it and
it's like i'm
able to do a bunch of like stuff outside
of my thing that like
freelancing and stuff like that where
people see my original ideas and they're
like man we love your videos like
can you do anything like that for us for
whatever
the opportunity is in that so it's like
i know there's a big market for people
that
like my stuff for like branding and
stuff like that and it's like i'm
view like i'm looking at my videos too
and it's like most of them are getting
some pretty decent amount of views
so like brands could reach out and like
make brand videos and like these videos
perform well so it's like maybe these
will be what brands want
if later in the future kind of thing
like it's right now i'm not too
too worried about like the actual like
long
term like making this a job kind of
thing i'm more of like
i'm just doing this for fun and seeing
kind of where it takes me like i'm
sitting in a
seaweed corridor right now and it's like
it seems to be working quite fine i
guess it seems to be working out but uh
no it's honestly i just enjoy it so much
like i
i think about it all the time like
what's the next idea and like
what's something that like might be
close to something that sees
someone seen before but like different
or like what's something
people can relate to but it's different
so it's
i don't know i i just really enjoy doing
this stuff so if you're thinking about
it that much and you're enjoying it that
much then
you know usually when those things are
happening and people are
seeing it and enjoying it as well then
it has a tendency to
to find its way into you know
creating a creating a path for you to
continue to do it so
yeah yeah that's i think i think your
mindset's in the right place
you know for for where you're at with it
because um
yeah you know you're you're 23. so
that's
it's a good spot to be with with the
decisions of hey let me just
let me just get better at this let me
just make it
more how i want it to be
let me enjoy it and then let let it sort
of land
um yeah that's smart yeah and
i'm learning a lot like too during the
process like i'm
interacting with companies and stuff
like that and like figuring out what
companies do like
and stuff like that but it's more like
yeah it's
i i wanted to not think of it as a job
yet like i'm
just i just want it to be like for fun
like that's yeah they're just videos
that i don't know
when you're young yeah it's like i think
or i know
i i have a really good feeling that this
stuff is going to work out for me
like in the future like it's just with
the amount of people seeing it and like
liking it and like the opportunities
i've already gotten and
stuff like that so it's like right now
i'm just i just want to enjoy it like
it's like i just want to make videos
post them see how people
think and like i i try different things
like i'll make a tutorial the odd time
or i'll make breakdown videos it's it's
just exploring this whole like visual
effects
kind of area and it's i don't know it's
a lot of fun
nice yeah no super cool i mean
like you know like worse comes to worse
you can just go get a job for any vfx
company doing houdini work
[Laughter]
[Music]
gonna have i'm gonna have to become a
lawyer if corridor fails
[Laughter]
yeah did i still think about that
frequently like
i'm fortunate i am not to have to like
go and work like an hourly
you know grind yeah like at this point
in my life
um you haven't been able to build up to
a spot where i'm
settled doing something i enjoy doing
takes it takes some work to get there
but
it's nice once you're there yeah yeah so
you know josh you talked about coming
into corridor after having like watched
videos of it and not to talk about
ourselves but like
i'm going to um i'm always curious it's
our podcast
josh i'm always curious like
you know so you've watched us online and
then you actually met us
what was like what was how did those
compare what you know column a
online version of us versus like column
b real life version of us
well besides the actual space like the
spacer is a lot smaller than what they
show on the videos like
the rooms are much shorter and like it's
more packed together
like they make it like see like it's a
like a big hall
or like a big room but it's it's not as
big as it's seen or something
yeah it's it's not as big as it is on
the videos but
uh besides that like meeting everyone
here on the first day was like it was
really nice like we sat down on monday
and we all talked and like
figured out like what everyone was doing
the week and we told like future
projects and stuff like that and it's
like
it felt really nice like meeting
everyone and like i got introduced uh
everyone and then i got sat down beside
bren
and uh wren just kind of like talked to
me for like two hours straight of just
like
visual effects stuff and like the
project i was working on i was kind of
showing him and he was giving me some
like
tips and stuff with that we just it's
really nice like talking to someone
that's very knowledgeable about visual
effects
like for a lot of the time like the
people i'm talking to
either have very little or like not
enough to be kind of on the same page
it's like i'd rather talk to someone
that like knows more than me just so i
can learn
and it's like yeah i i love like i love
talking to anybody about visual effects
don't worry
don't get me wrong but it's like
sometimes it's really refreshing to talk
to someone that really knows a lot so
when i was talking to ren it was like
this is really nice like it was like
we were just talking about like the most
nerdy visual effects things out there
but it's like
it means so much to me and then uh yeah
we
we played smash a bit like i got to uh
meet sam and nico
they came in and like shook my hand like
right away as soon as they came in that
was
that was super cool same with random and
stuff like that and yeah meeting matt
nat and everyone else it was it was
really cool like these guys are really
nice like they're
they're pretty much exactly like they
are in the videos great that's a great
that's a great read
um we'll have your check uh
i appreciate that no it's like you guys
are really nice like
when we were filming yesterday it felt
like you're filming with a bunch of
friends like you know like
the one-person films and like you're all
laughing and like everyone's kind of
like
peeking over the guy filming and like
checking the like the
playback of the like last recording
you're like is this good and you're like
yeah this is good and then like you're
making up stuff as you go and stuff like
that
i think that's like the best part about
filmmaking is like
keeping it fun and like like you makes
you
realize like how fun this kind of is and
like
how cool it is to have friends and stuff
like that with this like filmmaking
stuff so it's like
for the past year and a half i've been
doing it by my by myself pretty much
like i've got my uh i probably should
give a [ __ ] out to my sister
tanya for doing like all my filming so
nice
she uh she's been doing all the filming
with my stuff and it's so funny because
like i bought like the dji ronin and my
camera and all this but
she probably knows more of the settings
than me now because like she's been the
one filming all my videos and stuff like
that so
like i really appreciate her and like
everyone in my family that helps me with
the filming it's
it's really really cool that they uh
help me out and support me as much as
they do but
oh by the way speaking of filming we
filmed our first quarter short in a very
long time yesterday and you were
on the set for that i know it was how
did you feel about that yeah
it was a lot of fun like uh we had to
walk up a hill
i don't know why they made me carry like
the heaviest thing that's your
initiation
you have to you have to do
it's like i'm from canada obviously so
it's like a little bit cooler than it is
here
carrying the heaviest thing plus it
being uphill and like it was just
so hot yeah this is like as soon as i
got to the top of the hill i'm like
it's kind of gnarly yesterday yeah yeah
jordan had water rated like right ready
for everybody supposedly
able to drink water and stuff with that
and yeah no it was a lot of fun filming
with you guys yesterday and
seeing how you guys do it and stuff like
that no i i really enjoyed that
i guess we could spoil what the videos
about yeah should we
spend it yeah why not the cat it's the
for anyone listening
to the truth
everything gets spoiled on the trouton
podcast once it gets huge we'll stop
spoiling stuff right yeah first of all
first of all real quick a little bit of
perspective on this
i didn't know that we were shooting this
until monday
because we didn't come up with it until
monday you wrote it from monday
yeah so we were you know we were doing
son of a dungeon last week and i don't
remember how it came up it was probably
just a little thing we were riffing on
we were joking about it in the green
room
yeah that's right and then you know i'm
going i
go and i'm standing on the green screen
and like you know i'm waiting for like a
shot to happen so
my mind's wanting like what would that
look like i kind of started playing a
little video on my head and basically
the concept is
you know you see all those dumb
commercials that challenge your
masculinity to be like you know
soap for men shampoo for men
shaving cream for men shaving cream for
men
hell yeah lightsabers for men how could
you overly
masculinize a lightsaber and then
package it in a video with somebody just
like
reagan on you for all your decisions
like you know makes windows purple
lightsaber
like that's a huge transgression in this
world of like
masculine masculine lightsabers um
and just the idea to like you know
visual effects like lightsabers have a
very very very standardized way of
looking
it's always just a hyper like you know
rgb style
tube laser so it's like what if you made
it look really ugly
like what if you had an an olive drab
you know
lightsabers or you know the was it call
of duty brown
yeah you know all kinds of fun things i
reclaimed wood
like how in this universe call of duty
is masculine
hell yeah it is so masculine
if there's like one game that sums up
toxic masculinity
oh my god yeah
yeah constantly uh so you know and
the thing is we haven't shot a quarter
of a video in a long time we did the cut
scene
or rather sam did like 95 of it but we
didn't technically shoot it yeah it
didn't feel the same
yeah it was an animated piece yeah um
and so
you know as i said what screw it let's
just go shoot this it's easy it's like
two people
standing against some trees we can do
that we haven't shot a video in like
two years but we can do that and it was
you know it's also like the quick casual
kind of fun
uh setting that's a good like warm up to
get back into it you don't want to go
out there and be like all right now i
need like my five actors and my
two costume changes and my grip team
like yeah i mean the last thing that we
shot shot was when we were in texas and
we did
uh the black rifle commercial and then
we did um
the uh tactical three loads yeah yeah
that was
those are the last like big pieces that
we've shot and so
well tactical reloads was like in the
spring of 2020 and then we had the
domino's video spring yeah
right yep and you monster
yeah we had you monsters before we shot
that november
yeah sorry i'm really glad i'm really
glad that
like we are starting to
turn on those those fires again because
like that's what keeps you sharp you
know yeah it's just like here's a here's
a
here's a random like i've never shot
this type of video before
but you know i'm just gonna go with
go with what we have and shoot it and
make it work and yeah i mean a lot of
corridor videos are us pretending to
make a different style of video
but for you to pretend to make like say
a jason bourne fight scene it has to
look like a jason bourne fight scene so
you end up having to study how to make a
jason bourne fight scene
and even though yours isn't necessarily
like you know when you make your own
it's not necessarily as good as an
actual fight scene from jason bourne
but still if it's decent you still just
went and did all that practice which
has just made you a bit of a better
filmmaker even if you don't shoot any
more jason bourne fight scenes
you know you you understand ideally
you've taken away some of the
positives of like that style of
filmmaking that you can apply to
something else
right yeah yeah so basically we had to
order a lot of men's soap
and just like shower with it just shower
immerse ourselves in the masculine wait
to watch that movie never cried first
had to uh he wasn't allowed on the set
anymore yeah
who required last got to be the main
character i watched titanic three times
nothing nothing nothing
nothing yeah so keep your eyes peeled
for a video in like a week or two
yep with a bunch of goofy lightsaber
effects dubstep guns too got green lit
dumpster guns too got green light yes
the uh
the the the washed up sam and nico
get called on to they have to go get the
squad back together
yep yeah i threw on some really early
ideas with mike
and uh we'll get together we'll do like
a real brainstorm soon okay
yeah we're gonna have to go hard with
those vfx though on that video
yeah i'm scared
because i mean you can't it has to be
better
in terms of visual effects than the
first one don't put that pressure on me
[Laughter]
you were the one who wanted to put it up
on greenlight dude
yeah i think it's gonna be better in
many ways than just
the visual effects i feel like well yeah
here's the thing the first one was just
kind of a music video and while
it's true this will probably have some
of that you know i think the reality is
you know the first one was kind of just
a music video because back then
we weren't quite skilled enough
filmmakers to have
actual talking on screen and have it be
compelling
you want them to say what
you know just us doing the acting uh
back then i guess we still do a bunch of
acting on our stuff these days but like
i like to feel like we've grown as
filmmakers now we can actually have
dialogue scenes
and like put some story into it and have
the the reason it's good not just be
because we like killed ourselves doing
visual effects for like
way too many hours a day you know
obvious obviously
yeah there's got to be some dramatics
you know some drama to it
and some story yeah are you guys going
to use like
modern dubstep now like if before you
use like
dubstep that was like that was a big
thing back then but now it's like not as
big as it was that that's the joke of
the
of the video because it's like yes it is
yes that's just as cool as it was ten
years ago
there's there's still one club like in
our city that plays authentic dubstep
that's the one place that's where you
can always find
sam on like a saturday night
you know it's like yeah but uh
i mean i love the idea of building some
really dumb but funny world around this
whole thing
um which is honestly why i'm excited to
go back to it
but there are there is the idea i don't
know if i feel like we can work it in
the one thing i'm worried about doing
like one thing i'm worried about saying
sorry the one thing that pot makes me
pause when talking about creative ideas
on the podcast sometimes
or anywhere is when it's a simpler idea
that can just be done and somebody goes
oh well i'll just do that
and they just go out and do it you know
um
whether or not it was by coincidence and
we weren't necessarily going to do this
but it happened with mr beast and the
uber ride
we talked about like this is old this is
like four years it was
that was not coincidence
mr b what is the mr b super ride thing
we just we happened to have a connection
that had like
something like 30 000 miles of uber
credit
because just from some thing and we're
like what if we just ordered an uber to
go from california to
new york literally to go across the
united states and uber trip the guy
shows up he's like you get in the car
yeah the pot in that old san diego video
in fact it was called the sam and nico
channel
was like the idea of getting because as
an uber driver you don't know the
destination i guess until you pick them
up oh sure
she's like oh yeah all right he goes and
he hits he's like all right let's see
the destination it's like it doesn't
show up on his phone
like wait he zooms out he zooms out it's
like oh you're going to new york
it's like yeah i hope you brought some
uh spare clothes if you want to run by
your house it's the empire
state building yeah it's like yeah we're
going to be in this car together for
about
35 some thc some thc gummies if you want
to get in on it
exactly so we we laughed about it like
should we do it
should we make this video and all of us
were like i don't really want to sit in
a freaking uber car
when we made our video talking about it
so
you know i'm not that upset because like
i you know i wasn't
good i'm glad i'm glad he did it because
we would never have and somebody had to
do it and he was definitely the right
person to do it
i can respect him for doing it too yeah
so yeah the question i don't know if he
actually did it
just pointing that out just putting that
out there actually i heard there's
actually some things
in uber's software that keeps you from
doing those kind of rides but i don't
know
i mean here's the thing like we're going
to we're going to anchorage
no but seriously okay let me actually i
don't have a i deleted uber off my phone
because let's try it
i'm like let's try to like live location
from
san diego to like uh
nova scotia no i'll do it right now i'm
gonna enter empire state building
into my phone you're going on lift lift
i'm doing lift yeah yeah yeah
empire state building there we go third
and 55th avenue from downtown l.a
oh i can get a standard lift uh limited
availability gets me there by 9 36 a.m
availability
[Laughter]
trip exceeds maximum lift you know okay
but they do give me a time estimate if
that hypothetical lift were to happen
well
maybe four years ago things were
different with uber and you could
hypothetically man i mean let's see can
i go to las vegas
i think you can go i think i thought i'd
talk sooner or later
it immediately puts me into like the
whole like they actually have a thing
for
shuttling people from okay elliot to
vegas so it really popped me over to
that
okay never mind anyways yeah back then
they hadn't this has happened before to
them
well i haven't mr beast did it they're
like oh we should figure this thing out
i don't know but yeah
anyways we should go to we should go to
uh
europe and get one from like
you know paris to
like whatever the most remote location
in siberia we can find
oh my gosh jesus christ
from from paris to kamchatka that little
peninsula that comes off of russia
yeah that might be tough because we'll
be crossing international boundaries
that's true yeah yeah in the us we just
haven't just tell them
just tell them it's for a video they'll
get it i'm sure they'll understand
yeah just put it on your passport we're
youtubers
youtube was like yeah i know youtube
foreign countries love youtubers right
it's like the novelty wore off five
years ago guys
yeah you go to china you're like we're
youtubers they're like what
yeah that's true what we know though is
that dubstep guns can only be made by
corridor
so yeah there you go so yeah so i was
gonna throw out some
really funny ideas for dubstep guns but
i'm actually going to hold on to this
i'm sorry i'm sorry to even bring it up
okay i'm not even going to talk about
them
gosh dang it but it's just to say it's a
really cool idea and you wish you knew
yeah uh well you guys got a video to uh
finish uh indeed yeah
how'd the edit go did you did you edit
it through yet yeah we got an assembly
of it
yeah uh matt's great like we finished
the assembly matt's kind of just doing a
matte special and then i'm gonna do a
nico special and then we'll lock it
cool and that'll be good does joshua
have like a special effects
a special effect in this video or
yeah i told them uh i'm great at soft
bodies and like any kind of
dynamic stuff and they're like let's uh
let's give you a hair simulation
that i usually do but uh it's cool i've
done like a little bit of hair so it's
like it's not that big of a deal but
yeah yeah i uh been just fooling around
making a
bear hairy lightsaber
for bear pelt yeah bear fur or whatever
it was
yeah so it's yeah i just got a it almost
looks like a cat tail
and it's uh just sam waving around
yelling at the camera kind of things
sounds a lot of that
[Laughter]
i saw the outfit you guys put on him i'm
glad he i'm glad he took his hair down
for this and
oh yeah yeah it's funny like the outfit
he actually wore
i didn't realize he was in costume until
we were on set yeah
it's like an entirely normal attire yeah
but letting the hair down really like
brought it all together oh yeah
and when you put them in the wood
setting it looks like you actually found
him in the woods
so it's really perfect and one show with
the the tree stump as well
yeah that was that's we should put that
in my life was falling apart when i
started
oh you guys didn't put that in
uh yeah we gotta figure it we gotta work
out a couple of things for that but
we'll talk about that after the podcast
um
music stuff and you know just general
vibes yeah
yeah watch commercials a little bit more
do some like punches yeah
you got to do a little bit of sasquatch
research yeah dr squatch
dr squad and do some do some punches
don't forget your punches
punch ins absolutely i already added two
in my
my little sequence so okay there's no
more to come
your punch zooms and your and your
punch-ins oh we have organic ones we
have
artificial ones um combinations make
sure you put that shaky cam
that real thing camera shake on there
yeah oh yeah earthquake cam is what
we're doing good
good yeah so uh josh what's your
instagram channel
uh my instagram is just joshing and uh
your instagram is just joshing or is it
just
just joshing it's just joshing
just one just and then joshing
it's just just johnson or is it just
that joshing
it's just it's i'm just joshing
it's just josh
it's just that just josh at just josh
now no one knows
there's a guy who looks very similar to
me with a big head
like a big inflatable head that's that's
probably it if you
if you google it that's that's probably
me yeah
oh you ditched the croc one huh i did
yeah i thought it was just joshing
just joshing vfx that's uh that's my
tick tock because there is actually
someone that has just joshing on like
tick tock and youtube but you managed to
get just
joshing on instagram nobody had just
joshing before you got it
the funniest thing actually happened
with that like i uh
some guy had it and uh i was trying to
think of a name first i'm like do i just
do my
like just do i do just my
like real name josh it's so hard to say
now
am i gonna do joshua drury as like my my
name because i saw a lot of people doing
that and that's kind of like the style
people are doing nowadays is like
the person's name but i'm like ah let's
let's try to think of a name for
josh so i came up with a fewer and my
friends think of a few two and
like jolly joshua was one of them
there was like a like a few of them that
like it's this isn't it but then like
one night i was thinking just joshing
you
like oh somebody says oh i'm just
joshing you or something like that
so i tried just joshing and it was taken
just joshing you was taken
then i'm like maybe i could try
switching like the u with a v
or something like that so it kind of
looks it but like like nah this
this isn't it so the person who actually
had just joshing i messaged them i'm
like hey man like
i'd be willing to buy your name off of
you or something like that if you like
and it it went into his message i didn't
ever get a response
i i messaged him again like probably two
weeks later didn't get any response and
then uh
on the third time when i went back i
noticed that his uh
his name was changed he changed it to
like mr little or something like that mr
little
but with like a bunch of other numbers
after him
like i don't know how he went from just
joshing to like mr little like he's
77 6 or something like that
i don't know how you did that but like
as soon as i saw them like okay
there's like a two week period of like
the name is
they still have the name if they change
it for two weeks but then after it's
like free
free real estate i guess so i'm like all
right this is the day he changed it
let's put two weeks on the calendar and
like on this date just
as soon as i can in the morning just
like keep trying and trying and trying
and uh i was able to get and i'm like
thank you and i messaged him afterwards
dude yeah i messaged him afterwards i'm
like thanks man he's he still didn't
reply
i don't know if he changed it because of
me or he just felt like
mr little was the better name
after that he just changed it to your
welcoming
i feel like it hits like the nail right
on the top of the head for like the
stuff i do and like
my personality and stuff like that so
i'm super super happy that that's like
my brand name kind of now so
yeah and like just to celebrate like i
crossed like 50 000 followers on my last
video
i decided to make a hat and like my own
design and like get my own like little
merch
i guess like i'm not putting it out for
anybody or anything like that but
i thought i would get a hat of like my
little logo of like the big uh
the head it was like i was been wearing
it all week but then today i'm like no
i'll just go hair and then they're like
let's film a podcast
but uh yeah it was it feels cool like
making your own clothing for like your
brand and like
feeling proud of like your name and
stuff like that yeah yeah man
there's a little logo we got everywhere
yeah it's it feels like a little bit
more legit
it like it just adds a little bit to it
so i'm super glad i did that do you feel
that pressure when you have to make a
logo you're like oh my gosh i'm this
thing
i need to live with this thing forever
here you know ideally i'm like
putting it on everything i hope it's
good yeah it's
i don't really know if i have a logo yet
like i have my uh
my thumbnail is just like my head
inflated and like
just with me looking and uh
i don't know if it's like two it's not
really a logo it's just more of like a
photo
of me like just weird kind of thing
so i think that's gonna be the route i
take i don't want to really take like an
actual like
logo kind of like corridor digital it's
more of a logo than it is like the
actual
photo of something so i i think it's
going to be what i
stick with for a while because i pretty
much just branded everything with that
so
i'm hoping uh you don't want to change
it too often because then it kind of
don't worry
our logo on youtube was uh
a character from one of our videos in in
a mask
for i think three years
oh right that was our youtube soldier
from
yeah that was our channel icon oh really
let me change it to
well no actually no i'm sorry i'm
screwed up first it was
actually jake wearing his ghost from
modern warfare
okay it was that for like two years
three years
and then i think i changed it to like
the tether alien with like a bright
yellow green background and that one
worked really well just changing that
icon
got us a huge boost in subscribers we
got thousands because that icon changed
wow um so i guess it does it does matter
yeah uh and then i think we did the
prism guy for maybe a little bit
um and then yeah then we got the logo
now
yeah yeah sweet no you guys have one of
the nicest logos i've ever like seen
like it goes so well i can
i've been buying like your merch for a
while now and it's like not only
to support you guys it's like you guys
actually have like a really clever logo
and like it
it just looks nice so thank you and uh
it's it's really cool when you have
people come up and like notice it too
and they're like oh that's a really nice
hoodie and you're like
do you know the person that is like
it's like a quality to look at but yeah
no i i really like the corridor digital
logo
thanks the best thing about the
emergency green screen uh
hoodie is that you can change it to
whatever you want
um
but except weathermen and weather women
can't wear it because they won't show up
yeah they've they they're possible i
think they didn't show up for work
there's been numerous complaints from
uh meteorologists who are completely
dissatisfied with the product but
everybody else has been incredibly happy
we shouldn't have done the green screen
suit in time
we knew that was a bad idea yeah all
righty
cool well hey everybody thanks for
listening josh thanks for joining us on
this podcast looking forward to
knocking out some more cool lightsaber
shots the rest of the week with you and
uh also beating you for a second time
with a gannon versus ganon fight
um yeah i want the rematch
and uh i'll have to live stream that on
my story or something yeah
yeah we might have to livestream it too
we'll see and all you listeners out
there thank you so much for tuning in to
our podcast
once again we really appreciate it yeah
yes thank you
you have instagram it's just
your instagram handle
just just tell people what it is
if it's just an instagram handle
just know that it's just gonna be
your instagram handle
all right bye zeal is great